das ist ein spektakulärer durchbruch es
geht um die entwicklung von kern uhren
die noch exakter messen können als
atomuhren denn für die
grundlagenforschung im bereich der
physik ist es entscheidend wie genau
eine uhr geht denn manches lässt sich
nur verstehen wenn die zeitmessung
extrem präzise abläuft einem münchner
forschungsteam ist jetzt etwas
sensationelles gelungen doch die
entwicklung ist trotzdem noch lange
nicht abgeschlossen sie zum science
fiction
hier gibt's täglich spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur dann verpasste nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen das ist schon
wirklich krass in 30 milliarden jahren
gehen die besten atomuhren weltweit nur
um eine einzige sekunde falsch
damit gehören atomuhren zu den
genauesten instrumenten die menschen die
entwickelt haben
doch das alles könnte noch übertroffen
werden und zwar von den sogenannten kern
uhren diese basieren auf energie
veränderung im kern des isotops thorium
229 einem münchner forschungsteam ist
nun eine spektakuläre premiere gelungen
die fachleute konnten die energie die
beim zerfall des kerns frei wird ganz
genau vermessen
ein wirklich entscheidender schritt in
richtung kern und das ganze experiment
war nicht ohne
als taktgeber im kern uhren dienen
nämlich schwingungen im atomkern dieser
ist etwa 100.000 mal kleiner als die
atom hülle und somit auch deutlich
weniger anfällig für störungen doch das
ganze birgt auch enorme herausforderung
da die schwingungen in einem atomkern
viel schwieriger hervorzurufen sind als
in der atom- hülle bei gewöhnlichen
atomuhren fungieren nämlich schwingungen
in der elektronen hülle von atomen als
taktgeber das große problem ist jetzt
heutige leser sind nicht stark genug um
die atomkerne anzuregen
denn die energien dort liegen um mehrere
größenordnungen über denen der atommüll
ein guter kandidat jedoch ist das
thorium 229 hierbei handelt es sich um
ein isotop mit niedrig angerichteten
energieniveaus hier reicht in der
theorie ein leser aus der ultraviolette
strahlung produziert doch erst jetzt
gelang es den fachleuten die richtige
wellenlänge des lasers ermitteln der für
die anregung notwendig ist dazu der
physiker benedikt saller die energie-
beziehungsweise wellenlängen des
laserlichts muss haargenau auf die
energie des kern übergangs abgestimmt
werden
diese energie haben wir in unseren
experimenten nun erstmals genau bestimmt
das gelang folgendermaßen die fachleute
stellten thorium 229 juden her denen es
an elektronen mangelt und die somit
positiv geladen sind diese schossen die
experten und expertinnen dann durch eine
graf in folie
dadurch setzt ein dominoeffekt einen
denn die ionen holen sich die fehlenden
elektroden vom grafen und verlassen die
folie dadurch als neutrale atome der
angeregte kern zustand zerfällt der
atomkern gibt energie an dass elektronen
ab das so aus der atome wieder heraus
schiesst dadurch entsteht ein neues
seoane und mit einem elektronen
spektrometer konnten die experten dann
ganz genau analysieren wie viel energie
der atomkern an dass elektronen
abgegeben hat daraus schlussfolgert das
forschungsteam das für die anregung eine
story um 229 atomkerns ein leser mit
einer wellenlänge von rund 150 nanometer
notwendig ist dazu heißt es in der
studie
die energie des übergangs zwischen den
grundzustand und dem ersten angeregten
zustand entspricht an der wellenlänge
von 149,7 nanometern
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler sind optimistisch dass
auf grundlage dieser ergebnisse ein
geeigneter leser konstruiert werden kann
somit wäre der weg in richtung kern uhr
nicht mehr weit dazu der wiener physiker
thorsten schumm
das ist ein extrem wichtiger schritt für
uns wir wissen nicht nur dass es den
angeregten zustand knapp über den
grundzustand tatsächlich gibt wir kennen
nun auch seine energie recht genau
verloren könnten eine zeitmessung
ermöglichen die deutlich genauer und
robuster ist als mit gängigen atomuhren
robuster weil der atomkern deutlich
besser gegen störungen wie
elektromagnetische felder abgeschirmt
ist in der wissenschaft ist solch eine
hochpräzise zeitmessung anders als in
unserem alltag von riesigen vorteil auch
die überprüfung von naturkonstanten
könnte so präzise erfolgen ebenso wie
minimale unregelmäßigkeiten im
gravitationsfeld der erde experiment
laser fallen unüberwindbar anklicken
anschauen und brad den hammer kanal aus
unserem science network esn 1054
abonnieren
also hier klicken und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran